(sliding glass)
- Not tonight, I'm driving.
- Alcohol, alcohol, alcohol!
(car zoom)
- Hey.
Thanks for driving, man.
- Thanks, bud.
- Bartender, bartender.
- Gin and tonic.
- Whiskey sour.
- Gin and tonic, hey.
- Can I get a whiskey sour?
- Can I just get a water?
- Can I get a gin and tonic?
- Hey.
- Yeah, it was nice meeting you, Joe.
- Yeah, could I get your number?
Um, Li...
- Lindsey.
- [Lindsey] Sure, yeah.
- Lindsey, that's a dope name.
(upbeat band music)
(dings)
(car zoom)
(overlapping chatter)
- Taco Bell.
- Jack in the Box is open.
- No, chalupas.
- Guys, let's just do McDonalds.
(dings)
(car zoom)
- Thanks, man.
- No problem, dude.
- Have a good night, dude.
- You too.
- Thank you, Jordan.
- No problem.
(car zoom)
(camera shutter)
(dings)
(car zoom)
- Hey, thanks for the ride.
(cash register ding)
(car zoom)
(dings)